okay guys it's your boy psychobabble and
we're playing a game today called con
clues I'm talking right now because I'm
pretty sure this thing just Auto starts
like holy Italy deal yeah here we go
okay
Canada
hey that's disgusting
okay I guess that's that Pappas oh okay
okay then we just check to see if Y is
the resolution so hi intended now okay
not really any thanks but let's try this
oh yes where's that man I don't know
we'll find out empty
- is this is like some help
would you really be here
ah really sad really sad after three
years of searching for your missing wife
Carolyn so you'd non miss tip lie welder
we thought it was called hell you
thought joke but first Patricia met that
lets exist now she had to arrive you
wonder if could it be true this is
exactly the plot of Silent Hill okay
mmm
much better bet favor in the band
now I better find that one you know
he like needs a picture because you
can't remember what you look like
kind of loose
what does that mean like conclusion over
clothes oh wow okay okay look next use
open editors accept but he is too open
that's kind of confusing but will channa
okay
China I hit the train
the door is partially open but won't
budge oh I see I can't say any car bar
what is that
it's all wrong move okay well the puzzle
started immediately there's some sort of
mechanism okay that works
hello buddy she gave birth
okay I get attention we should react
nerds mr. leave her alone okay I say so
uh here we go okay trying to pick this
up but it will know how you pick it out
okay okay I got it baby I got it
there's a crowbar I'm pushing hard as
you can okay wait did it baby oh I did
it
whoa
forget dark in here yeah flap side now
head out with a flashlight plus it's
going on needs a K needs K this trash
can have their king
sometimes future okay to sit on a star
has any key is are on here anyone see
any case that is that I don't know what
that is and I don't care to find out
okay I'm looking for keys keys Eric
Hayes
you got any case mr. if that's [ __ ] yeah
I'll be [ __ ] they don't believe in
like a a [ __ ] fence well they made
one I have chains I'm just bein order to
put up and down every day okay what is
that that [ __ ] is that the [ __ ] is that
Wow okay
the [ __ ] is Talib yeah hey yes quiet as
a mouse
and I can hear Ches in here looking for
some K [ __ ]
Ches Ches Ches yeah there are no keys in
here I saw this up out get back in
I gotta go back in to get some keys this
is crazy
this is just crazy a dagger that's her
for a K or something do you have a K
Lenny
oh my god I'm already this deep and I
don't have a king give it back
I need a kale Eddie I need a king the
keys in hand and I ain't got keys in
this joint okay what the hell am I
missing then anything over here now let
me take one more peek down here I really
don't think you than I do down here but
you know if right now with these games
you really never know okay is now Kings
in that case okay there's no case
there's no case okay well we've still
gotta find that fact now we're gonna go
upstairs and giant look for a mr. Kay
okay mr. Kay na Kay's in here [ __ ] what
can the ground or something random key
on the bench a bench the bench kitty you
were here those they're pretty good
downtown what what is this one
so she is
okay okay yeah she's just napping oh my
good thank goodness there's this kid in
the trash can here employee gate okay
there where you go where you got it guys
but she was solved what is this oh my
god mister boland man hey not seeing
that
he has a below take pyramid head
okay way that affects me I'm not
bothered by it you know it's really fine
I'm not bothered by it because you know
like everybody has the places to be you
know I hope my third job should that guy
yes I think it's over a year
Jesus no no okay whose luck here he's a
key but look me I have it kay what is
that trash trash trash then all I can to
keep anyone from entering this area not
like I've seen us all anyway me where if
you're the one writing this at this
plants yes that has plans ahead dick
right over stop something bad is
happening here take my advice get back
on the subway in length I have to warn
you about something else maybe say a
woman with long black hair and the
seller attention don't talk to her she's
on credit hold if you must better put
over the heater in Locker but make sure
you lock everything behind you this
place is dangerous
the janitor can take this corner and
I'll take this car out of town
thank you thank you okay where's the
locker here it is
janitors Ches yeah I got at my chouchou
daddy in here they're all update so I
guess we unlock that crazy [ __ ]
which is like really like if it was
actually dangerous like like anybody
could just slip through here still like
this is a lot of work for nothing
it keeps fall to the ground
messing black-eye server eyes at a black
marker okay you get quarter
that's it Carolyn I just went off well
that was a waste of I call I think I
have one more quarter come on trying to
call here trying to call here can I make
one call I have two quarters did Matt
what the hell I guess huh still abroad
yonder you know you can only make one
call yeah yeah that's nice I see it
place up the [ __ ] [ __ ] how's this
Trenton New Jersey another call oh my
god
Matt call mom she always picks up every
time
that is so weird yeah okay
that was a really weird call no it does
about yeah what is that over there
what is that x marks the spot
appliers it's an estranged substance
what is that piece of bread
okay okay turn okay fascinating and one
of the quarter
what is your great let's see what I say
is them one man again what the [ __ ] is
that
he's even closer
have another quarter
No what's that this cigarette smells
familiar
take quarters in here if I had wars okay
Trash Can eonni quarters in here no man
I blew all my quarters
what is that leaving stuff a gigantic K
on the ground but it's a small key
beheaded rat huh
dark figures can be seen under the water
on a nearby sure what is that no
laughter sounds like he's crying what
the [ __ ] well it is laughter it's really
hard and it's weird that laughter could
be like either were what is that I don't
see oh my goodness
why didn't what is he like noticing I
hear noise but did I seriously my
something
what the [ __ ] okay a security card
because I'm gonna hospital next class
refer couple Street Hospital lose in the
distance whoa which is dark death at
2:30 of quarter okay okay I just got a
key here so death at 2:30
okay oh that's what cake well that's a
230 mm
so me taking a picture of this holds
that gonna get my camera
take a picture this
okay I got it since going on here
you got a crazy-looking k nope not that
way no this way
I used to death cake oh [ __ ] your
[ __ ] blue door what is that dead cats
oh and now it's him again oh no
loading
[Music]
that's so weird okay I don't what those
about we really don't know what that's
about
yes you saw my quarters up on that thing
let me go back really quick I know it's
a pain in the neck but it's definitely
something going on because every time I
look at that binoculars every turn this
is about me getting closer or so okay
whoa holy [ __ ] I lost it we're back
where I live that was insane
hospital security guy okay I'm here good
I'll catch you later she'll have your
skin freakin dark in here dude papers
I'll take this k thank ya okay hey hey
trash cans here yeah name is computer
power at all but nothing happens
burnt man now I've accessed the hospital
man
let me freaking save real quick beat one
no-bake to know so what's the other side
know what that is
let's go let's go baby seven before go
Sam
pretty short neck decollete button just
to be thorough you do the see isn't a
large sheet of Bolton metal bolted
printing forward he had a pair of pliers
no I took out two bars how's that
worth a okay okay freakin dark in here
did other button doesn't work okay I'll
keep looking very sad very sad paintings
what happens when you have to go to uh
well chair goodwill to get you garlic
close
there's just something is wrong nearby
say this area is what gonna go shopkins
are everything comedians what is rotten
nearby Carol
okay another waste of time
as I call it like one call or a payphone
so annoying
there we go
take the lefty now let's find out what's
rotting in this disgusting down did all
the things are crooked
how's this
this looks like Scooby's jump-scare
mansion where's the placards are all
empty I don't know what that is
so chair what is this
okay Nick a by taking that now my love
faster a lot faster soon here nah all
right a lot of bodies that's fine now
none of my best no see now it's a
hospital what they do is what they do
matter okay okay
at least I self explained it to her I'm
guessing it said water on the roof okay
Canyon and a lot of climbing in this
game what is there an option for a
flashlight I can't remember I feel like
it was one but that's not true because
there isn't one
that's see as fast how didn't eat Kiva
that time to get that piece of paper
that's glowing
he's yours empty
let's say what we're gonna say here yeah
this is good yeah it gets that far but
nothing embarrassing candle
and that's a disgusting that is
disgusting
and I'm accepting to the toilet and
that's that thank you that sweet that
guy that's sign they keep coming back
the only way to stop them is to harm
their bodies just don't inhale the fumes
okay I guess that's good advice
what is that generator still on ahead
you King uh-huh
circle bro don't [ __ ] a circle bro
let me swap meet I hate this place it's
scary
can I make orders to take from him
we've let our King alright yeah that's
gonna be again what is this another VHS
tape tape the three of three where's the
second one that we'd like to go back and
watch them
I know it's saved in a while and I don't
feel like playing the whole game over
again you know you know it is perhaps um
I like it how the hell are you back
yes it's me this is being hopping along
don't mind me
hey bad chest tapes around here no no
what's this way
yeah ii of the edge in a statement tarot
of three that guys we'll do is we'll
watch these two and I'll end it there
for now now I came from like here there
we go
it's finding hope this is an
inappropriate
ah going down these welcome very slowly
just fell may even know he noses nothing
exciting
he just likes using up space that is
knocking
no one is knocking what
someone's like drilling me to drive me
crazy
at me it's just take three luckily I
haven't them that buzzing
yeah
hey % persuade me or something okay it's
a tape of 3pi tape 3 what we're just now
up the ladder
yeah fast forward I guess yeah okay I'm
in there it's a guy over there watching
TV oh that's me
holy Toledo like a hospital tape worm
bait it's awesome
how do I get back no maybe wait is that
wait what the hell how do I get back
oh great okay let me get back and save
and then we'll continue okay
what the hell is this
there's just the tape nicer to us okay
we get back the best way to get back
oh no it was this way they get you back
mm-hmm weird I don't know what's going
on in this game it's getting them to
like the classic okay
okay that works take a look back
downstairs I think
alright step need to make sure I'll have
to go back up yet no iced down well well
well hmm this one is a good checkpoint
here
well where's the main entrance yeah this
way
oh yeah I cut through it like a million
fences it messed up
mm-hmm okay I'm we're gonna end here
before we enter hospital from baby yet
all right thanks for watching y'all I
hope y'all enjoyed see you in the next
one